we're coming back two volumes we're
circling back around to it piling the
pun
partly because there are lots of things
to look at in volumes just like an
integration you're going to see later on
today there are techniques to be able to
work out these volumes that seem to have
nothing to do with volume so I'll let
mrs. Leeds I won't spoil what she's
going to show you shortly but that'll
come later on I want you to have a look
at this shaded area I've put on the
board
I've given you the equation of this
parabola I've given everything you need
to know about the boundaries of it to
work out what that area is we're going
to we're kind of volume to do with this
area but I want you to have a think for
a second just use your intuition I know
that you haven't got all the information
you absolutely need but if you were to
work out a volume associated with this
region which way do you think the volume
would go just take a guess because you
can go in two directions right which way
would you guess that it goes I can see
most of you do it with you you're
probably guessing it should go around
the x-axis right that's a very good
guess what's the cue that gives you that
yes well for starters you seem to have
been given the X boundaries this is at
least a start so if you've been given
expounder YZ it's not that outrageous to
assume you're going to be evaluating an
X volume right not only that but you see
how you've got the 0 in the 2 down here
this region is bounded by the x-axis do
you see that right it's the curve and it
goes underneath so if you were to ask
for the Y like going around this way you
would expect to have this area shaded in
here which is bounded by the y axis yeah
but you do not here's why we left this
for a little bit later you can work out
this volume this shaded area around the
y axis and that's what makes this
particular volume challenging ok so go
ahead draw your little revolution arrow
what's going to happen when we rotate
this around the y axis
well what's this thing going to look
like just take a minute for a second
take a minute for a second take a moment
they figured out that potter's wheel
again think about which way it's right
hey think about the shape you're going
to get hmm now I'm going to pause for a
moment I'm gonna get you to try to draw
this volume before I show you what it
looks like okay it'll take you like 15
seconds draw even if it's like
completely wrong I want you to try and
apply your mind to imagine what this is
going to look like if we want to spin it
around the y-axis okay so I have some I
have some interesting shapes appearing
on pages quite a few different versions
okay here's what I want you to picture
here's a bit of a tip for you we're
rotating right we're rotating so the
object that you're going to get always
ends up with rotation or symmetry every
time because you know whichever axis
you're going around you're creating the
same shape you just rotating it's
spinning it so you get a rotationally
symmetrical object right if it's
rotational symmetrical and it's around
this line then see this interval over
here this vertical line it should appear
exactly the same everywhere you look
around the rest of the edges of the
shape right so it should extend out this
way out of the whiteboard and it should
whip all the way back around and come to
this opposite side so see how you have
two over here you can guarentee and
negative two you will get the same line
over on this side even if what you had
was not I'm just I've given you an even
function which is kind of convenient but
if I'd given you a cubic don't worry
about drawing this if I've given you a
cubic and I'd said okay look at this
area I'm shading right now do you see
it's more or less the same shape as the
one that I gave you over here right for
all intents and purposes if I were to
rotate this around the y-axis even
though like this guy goes down here this
is actually the area I'm interested in
right so it looks like it would be
something like this you're going to get
that spinning around do you see that
like this part over here becomes
irrelevant because it is not part of the
region being rotated does that make
sense I gave you this one because it's
sort of easy you'll get this
be on both sides okay right so you can
see you know sort of on profile this is
the edges of our shape right but it's
rotating I want to try and capture that
so I'm getting something like this do
you see that this top edge is going to
rotate around and you're getting sort of
this ball shape right it's not just the
top that rotates you've also got the
bottom right do you see that's rotating
around I can't actually see through the
object so I'm gonna make that a dotted
line underneath there does that make
sense do you see what's going on each
part of this region will rotate around
so I'm looking for each part okay one
more thing I'm going to do just to give
my mind a little bit of helped you need
to put this in no but it helps you
visualize what's happening the inner
surface of this volume the inner surface
which comes from the parabola right it's
all curved it's all curved so you sort
of have like a bowl right it's empty in
here so I'm gonna put these kind of like
rotating lines because you can see
inside the shape you can sort of peer
over the top edge right that is the
volume that we're interested in that's
the volume we're trying to find okay so
think about this we normally have two
ways V equals V equals to workout
volumes that come from solids of
revolution two ways right they both
start with an integral right the very
first time we had a look at this we were
at angle on the x-axis do you remember
that that was how we started so we went
from A to B what were the things we were
adding up again we're adding up
cylinders which start with a pi the
radius squared if you're going this way
the radius is a vertical thing right so
that's why you ended up with y squared
DX remember that this is when you're
rotating around the x-axis what changes
if I rotate around the y axis well for
starters I need some new boundaries I'm
not gonna write a to B just to give
myself a mental cue that they're
different boundaries they're gonna be
these boundaries right I'm you're still
doing cylinders so you still have a PI
but then what changes x squared dy so
you can see just to remind you the
operative variable is this one down here
right you rotating around the x-axis
integrate with respect to X
you rotate around the y axis you
interact with respect to Y okay which
one of these do you think I'm going to
need to use not a trick question I'm
gonna have to use the second one right
because I have nothing to do with the
rotation around the x-axis so I already
know that this is the one I'm interested
in but by itself
it won't cut it by itself if I just use
this on this what boundaries would I put
in like that's the first thing you got
to write down this is a little trickier
what boundaries do you think I should
put in where did the boundaries come
from they usually come from this region
that you're looking at here right where
it goes from top to bottom okay but
there's a bit of a weird thing happening
here if you went from 0 up to what's
this value at the top it's 5 right 2
squared plus 1 so I might as well put
that in if I went from 0 to 5 0 to 5
what would be the region that
corresponds to that hmm now I can try to
shade it I can try but I'm going to run
into some problems right from 5
downwards I'm gonna get don't put this
in because your daggers gonna get too
busy I'm gonna get this kind of area
right do you see that this is bounded by
the y-axis okay but then it gets to 1
that's 1 and then there's no region down
here so there's no area so how can it
rotate around 0 at 5 doesn't give you
something sense of what's early does not
give you this volume ok so what I'm
trying to get at is this on its own
doesn't give you the shape that you need
in fact it sort of gives you the
opposite like we've got this sort of
ball looking shape right it's hollow on
the inside if I went from 1 to 5 you'd
get the hollow on the inside the part
that I don't want ok so now think back
think back to what you were looking at
with areas and we looked at differences
of areas I am going to need to use this
but it just isn't the whole picture
it gives me the part inside the part I
don't want how do I get the part that I
do work okay so look at the whole shape
just sort of take a step back and look
at the entire thing you've got this
whole cylinder right which is five units
high and it has a radius of two do you
see that
maybe we should all label them okay this
height is equal to five and this radius
is equal to two is a big cylinder which
is the outside of the shape and as where
we sort of dig out we carve out this
inside bit the curvy bit right so what
I'm doing is actually taking the
difference of two volumes their
difference of two volumes I know how to
do that volume equals okay what do I
begin with I'd begin with the entire
cylinder just one whole cylinder so it's
PI what are in this case two times the
height which in this case is five it has
to go all the way down to the bottom
right so there's that part that's the
whole cylinder but what I want to carve
out hence the subtraction is this inside
bit what happens when I take the red
area and rotate that does that make
sense
so I'm going to form the integral it's
from one to five because it's going
around the y-axis so I'm interested in
why boundaries and it's gonna be PI look
look down there x squared dy right
because I'm rotating around the y axis
so Y boundaries with respect to Y does
that make sense okay that was the hard
part working out like putting all the
pieces together the rest of it I just
have to do a bit of evaluation and some
simplification okay bit of substituting
so what's the whole cylinder gonna be
higher times 4 times 5 20 PI should I
approximate that there was no reason to
it doesn't end up neater we can you do
so I'm just gonna leave it exact what
have I got over here
well one to five PI what is x squared I
don't want X
I want to in terms of wires right so
over here you can see I just need to
subtract one from both sides whoops and
not rub it out while I'm doing that that
will give me x squared on its own so why
take away one equals x squared
that makes it's like do you see why I
did that I want to know what x squared
is so I can get rid of it okay so Y
minus one at this point it no longer
looks like a volume question it's just
an integral you guys can take over let
me give you 20 30 seconds work out what
the primitive is go ahead and evaluate
it and then let's see what we get at the
end okay happy yeah okay so you worked
out your primitive you evaluated it you
can see at this point here would I be
upset if you wrote like four squared on
2-0 no but I like doing something like
this because it doesn't take me a huge
amount of time and it gives me an easy
way to work out like if I did something
wrong if it's a bit ridiculous down the
bottom I can work out where that error
happened